[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis un peu timide
comment faire
face à tout ce que mes craintes mes
grands frères et grandes soeurs
je veux aller dans le même pas que ma
gang tout à l'heure elle apparaît de
fait face l'espagne
lui fait face aux états dans le sens où
comme à bord dès qu'on décidé qu'on fait
le meilleur choix
pour pouvoir venir lorsque un obstacle
qui se disent eux mêmes sur votre chemin
et que vous on peste que vous empêche
d'avancer
je suis maudit kabran fadiga je suis
venu à un handicap et à un accident plus
tôt
mais je suis je veux sur cet handicap
[Applaudissements]
l'environnent la vie est un perpétuel
recommencement
et l'environnement nous sommes évolué
comme nous évoluions aussi
celui qui était il ya cinq ans
cette photo
c'est pour cette même personne
qui est maintenant
qui est devant vous maintenant et c'est
grâce à cette dame avec laquelle je suis
sur cette photo qui m'a grandement
avec beaucoup d'amour et beaucoup
beaucoup d'attention et beaucoup de
soutiens
qui m'ont permis
de faire face à ce handicap
à pouvoir me tenir devant vous reparler
de ce mot qu'on cache
parce que dans notre culture ou
plus et plus en plus vu en afrique un
une personne en situation de handicap et
comme gardien au placard
il ne peut rien faire il ne va rien
faire et on le laisse là jusqu'à ce
qu'ils atteignent alors que ce trésor
inestimable
enfouis sous la terre comme le diamant
comme le leur et tous qu'il faut
exploiter pour finir fait sorti la
valeur
et les croire qu'il cas d'ennui
phase c'était
un 18 novembre 2007
quelques mois après a reçu mes résultats
mon bac et
gt1 nouveaux étudiants dans les forêts a
cherché à nouvelle faculté a cessé à
s'inscrit et tout
est devenu comme les autres
je passe rapidement faire des petits
bisous à grenay
manger pour le petit-déjeuner
continue ma vie un maroni
au cours de la soirée
je viens racines
souviendra c'est la voiture dans
laquelle j'étais
et
ont fait un accident
les pompiers arrivent et là je prend
automatiquement
lorsqu'on a fait là sinon je suis sorti
par la vitre arrière parce que je t'aime
côté invités derrière le véhicule est au
milieu notes après plusieurs tonneaux
plus on va vite arrière
je me retrouve
étalés sur le sol
est là
et allait pomper disent arriver tout je
prends connaissance
et ils disent vont m'envoyer au chu de
yopougon
où ceux qui connaissent les qualités de
chevaux
ne vous dis pas deux élus eelv mon
voyage des plus grands nous et refuse la
première décision
de dire je ne ris je n'irai pas au chu
de yopougon
mais envoyer mon hôte dans un autre
centre hospitalier sauf celui de cheveux
blonds
marais que j'étais petit je partage
discuter avec les poneys les pompiers et
à mumbai au chu de cocody
où là je n'ai pas pu me faire opérer
parce qu'ils ont pas descendre
néologique
parce que j'avais un problème de nerf
donc
malheureusement ou heureusement moi ça
me ramène à yopougon au lieu de départ
et
arrivée au chu de yopougon c'était quand
même difficile parce que nous sommes
arrivés aux environs de 9 ans et au
cours
de la journée a mis nu certaines font
savoir qu'ils peuvent pas mon père est
pourquoi si on m'opère je meurs
quelle décision prendre
ma grand mère
wagner prend la décision
encore cette dame
prend la décision
coûte que coûte qu'on fasse l'opération
on part donc dans le principe non dans
mon père et et l'as hautmont voir une
clinique du vers la droite ou
le suivi l'opération
mais c'était pour moi tout ce temps
c'était comme si
c'était rien de grave c'était comme si
c'était une simple blessure ou un pied
cassé la mer plate ici un mois ou deux
mois je reprends ma vie comme si de rien
n'était et tout et c'est toujours le
même credo matin
rien à sauver et l'opération rentrent en
salle d'opération
hostens à l'opérateur et tout est en
le médecin du chirurgien me le gaz
et commence à me parler je
désirais pas mon dos me que je veux
aujourd'hui gavé l'opération
inocap château domine donc en rigole
même d'arras et
je me réveille
je sors un mal au niveau de ma cause
tout est là je me rends compte que
l'opération est terminée
et que c'est maintenant que je sais
c'est qu'elle ait tous que tout petit
faire en moins de six heures de temps
par la grâce de deux survécu et voir
yvan offroy maintenant farce aux
réalités
qui s'impose à moi et à ma vie
en main dit je suis traître appelé gic
ce qui signifie j'aurais pas la
motricité de mémé et de mes pieds je ne
sens pas si c'est pour ma tête je ne
sens pas jusqu'à tout mon corps chose
que
immédiatement la décision que je prends
fondement je refuse
ce diagnostic
qui me dit que j tétraplégique
et donc
maintenant il va falloir fédérer
ducation
on me ramène au chu de yopougon
comme quoi le jus pouvons est mort
nous avons une histoire d'amour
la barre éducation se passe et
vervins voisin qui était la voir en
avant par oman
et qui avait le même problème que moi
et je le voyais manipuler son téléphone
moi j'arrivais pas parce qu'on dit tu
vas pas et vu que j'avais déjà
enlevé sans à cette idée de ne pas
pouvoir bouger mais ne pas pouvoir
donc je me dis je peux me demande
comment il fait pour une plus son
téléphone hélas le confie vu que c'est y
avait ma soeur avec mon jeu qu'on fixe
sont-ils iphone et j'apprends jeu avec
beaucoup de difficultés de manu sa pompe
sont les fantômes et où on l'appelle je
me suis silencieux et puis je continue
ma rééducation personnel et au bout de
quelques temps je commence à brûler les
doigts
le concept gérer doigts
c'était formidable c'était déjà
un premier acquis
un espoir rennais en mon jeu multi c'est
possible encore de faire face aux
obstacles et ses positions vont pas d'y
arriver et là je reprends des études où
je les avais laissés
actuellement le schéma ce que je suis en
master dont deux domaines différents en
marketing et en coopération
internationale et du britannique
[Applaudissements]
comme quoi
c'est vrai que la vie n'est pas facile
et c'est vrai que la vie nous ne ferons
pas de cadeau mais
ce sont les décisions que nous prenons
qui seront le résultat de ce que nous
attendons
la société
ne peut pas nous donner tout ce qu'on a
besoin on a envie à nous-mêmes d'aller
chercher sur la comco h 10 si la société
ne s'adapte pas à toi toi adaptons à la
société
j'ai fait un chemin je prends les
décisions qu'il faut et tu te bats tu
poses des actions et tu avances
6e
je vais acheter un fait si un petit mot
avant de finir mais tout ce parcours a
été fait grâce à l'amour que j'ai reçu
de ma famille des personnes que je ne
connais ce que je connaissais même pas
je suis les réseaux des personnes
bienveillantes dont le taxi ou dans le
bus parce que je prends le budget jfl
effet une espérance les essayer de
prenez plus quelques trois fois et tout
et je salue s'il salue cette initiative
de la sotra qui a mis d'abus sort où il
ya des trappes ou des personnes en
situation d'handicap sa salle ce qui
veut dire que la société en train
d'évoluer et voilà ça me plaît bien et
où donc en gros c'est grâce à l'amour et
aux décisions que j'ai appris
qu'ils m'ont permis d'arriver et de tout
de tout continuer à me battre et relu et
aujourd'hui ils ont dit que j'allais pas
pouvoir bouger mais je n'ai pas pouvoir
sont ils gérés pas pouvoir faire ce si
j'allais parfois mais aujourd'hui
j'arrive à bouger les mecs j'arrive à
continuer mes études
j'arrive à rédiger des projets que je
veux réaliser et tout
comme quoi tout est possible
crois
[Applaudissements]
tu veux fait imposer tu veux réaliser tu
veux te barrer tu veux avoir des enfants
croire en cela et tu es tu mets les arcs
sont qu'il faut tu poseras son qu'il
faut et tu es arrivera mais si
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]